and where do you see the animal manifest
in life
on on a primitive level it is
uh it appears in men generally
as a an element of romantic
unreal mostly sexual fantasies
and you see for instance in puberty when
young men
are very active and then suddenly they
become passive
and dreamy and they are not there and
their
performance in school goes down
tremendously
and one has the feeling where is that
where has that young man disappeared
he's in the clutches up to the neck
of daydreamings sexual fantasies
in that age it is a normal transition
but if a man gets stuck
in indulging in
wishful sexual fantasies
he literally falls into the hand of a
vampire
he he loses his capacity of taking his
own life
in hand he loses his will power he loses
all his male
efficiency and he just daydreams all
this time
about women and their curves and would
be
romantic adventures and so on
he lives in an unreal life i saw once a
man who was
43 still living with his mother who had
never
approached a woman he
he i i asked him what on earth are
you doing with your sex and he gave a
secretive smile
and didn't confess he he just
masturbated widely every night
and delhi then he dreamt that he was in
daytime living an ordinary life but in
the night time he was living
on a luscious island where he had wild
sexual adventures with women
that was a fantasy world into which he
had disappeared
in a primitive tribe one would say such
a man has been bewitched
he's bewitched we would say he's locked
into an infantile attitude to life
he's being devoured by the mother